[Music]
foreign you are watching The Press
preview of first look at what's on the
front pages as they arrive in the next
half hour we'll see what's making the
headlines with author and journalist
Rachel shabby and Daily Mail conist
Sarah Vine so let's see what's on some
of those front pages for you now the
front of the Metro says some ambulance
workers abandoned their strike to dash
to 999 emergencies
the eye predicts that turmoil in the NHS
will last days with bigger strikes to
come in the new year
the mirror accuses the government of a
deadly silence and says they won't talk
pay to anyone
the front of the telegraph says the NHS
will be offered a new pay deal to end
their strikes
the express says the number of 999 calls
plummeted during today's strikes amid
fears people were suffering at home
the guardian Mourns the Health Service
may become overloaded with a surge of
patients after days of strikes
DFT says U.S tech Giants are ditching
offices in London and Dublin as years of
Rapid expansion are brought to a halt
hit cop drama line of duty is returning
to TV screens that's on the front of the
Sun
the male says that driving home for
Christmas
is uh going to be a bit of a chore but
we don't have the front of the mail for
you
and reminded that by scanning the QR
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's newspapers while you
watch us and we are joined tonight by
Rachel shabby and uh Sarah Vine there
you both I thought one of you had um
deserted us but you're both there good
good to see you let's start with the
guardian and they're suggesting that the
NHS is braced for research in patients
because a lot of people
um took
advice not to call in to the ambulance
service and dial 999 and stayed at home
and suffered at home but the
repercussions of those will knock on
into the days to come Rachel
yeah that's right so the guardian is
reporting exactly as you say people did
stay at home
um and heed that warning to stay at home
during this day uh when the ambulance
workers were out on the strike for the
first time in 30 years and so now in the
days up to Christmas when you know staff
is streamlined anyway in those days
there's the fear that there will be an
extra load on
um on the NHS as people who essentially
delayed seeking care will now be doing
so that the guardian notes that this
will be quite similar to you know what
happened during covid-19 during the
lockdowns when people basically have
avoided seeking care
um and then the NHS dealt with this huge
backlog so it won't be the same scale
but it's the similar kind of pattern now
obviously with you know both the nurses
out for the stroke for the first time in
their history and the ambulance workers
as well
um you know the trouble for the
government here is that they both do
have widespread support people know why
they're on strike people understand why
they're on strike and two-thirds of the
population support them uh which makes
the government's refusal to even go to
the negotiating table over such a
critical issue in such important and
valued workers it just makes them look
belligerent and obstructive yes and the
Guardians reporting that a hangover from
the ambulance strike is that the wards
will be Fuller over Christmas and that's
just the time when actually they operate
on a skeleton staff Sarah
yeah I mean I think a lot of
um maybe some people who uh didn't call
an ambulance today won't need it because
if they are you know genuine emergencies
they might find that they that they that
that emergency has gone away but yes I
mean there is a there is I mean it's
always difficult over Christmas because
as you say there are fewer there are a
few staff generally and people tend to
wind down
um but you know also over Christmas
people tend to drink rather a lot and
fall over and do things that perhaps
they wouldn't normally do so it is it is
difficult
um I don't know if
um I I mean I I do think quite a lot of
people support these strikes but I'm not
sure that uh when it comes down to it if
you're the person who can't get an
ambulance if you're having you know if
you've got something wrong with you
having a stroke or your child is sick
whether that will translate into
continued support so it's very difficult
for these uh Strikers because they have
to find a balance between
um you know pursuing what they want
which is a pay rise and not fund
mentally going against their
vocation which is to help people and
keeping public on side as well to it's
the politics of it all and the mirror
they quote they won't talk pay to
ambulance Crews they won't talk pay to
hospital Porters they won't talk to
nurses they won't talk pay to anyone
they're accusing the government of a
deadly silence Rachel
yeah and I it's it's in it's interesting
what Sarah says about you know the the
the calibration over public support and
the politics of it all I mean I think
the trouble for the government is that
its own popularity is pretty low you
know it's it's polling around 20 20 to
25 percent and what the polling is
showing with all of these strikes
actually to varying degrees but
overwhelmingly with NHS workers is that
if people are inconvenienced which of
course they are I mean strikes by
definition they're supposed to be
inconvenient they aren't blaming the
people who are on strike they're blaming
the government or you know in the case
of say Railways uh the companies running
those railway lines and so that's going
to be a huge problem for the government
that that message has been understood by
the public and we've all heard the
nurses and the ambulance workers we all
know and understand that they are doing
it actually to protect the healthcare
service which they say at current
Staffing levels and and their current
experience of it is is endangered it's a
danger to patients and they worry about
patient safety now of course we all you
know we all
are worried about this we we all have
loved ones who are vulnerable and worry
about what might happen to them
um but I I do think that it's
interesting that that overwhelmingly
there is this public understanding that
that is not the fault of the nurses and
the ambulance workers the blame for that
lies squarely uh with the government
well at the unite Union is saying that
the government could have ended the
strikes but chose not to that's a direct
quote just uh finally we've just got
time to have a look at the eye
um Sarah and they're predicting that
there'll be bigger strikes in the new
year
yeah I mean it's clear that they're not
going to back down I mean they are they
are asking for 19 which is a lot
um and they I you know I I think that is
unreasonable to be perfectly honest
um they've rejected they haven't lost it
they have asked to negotiate they have
asked for talks
so one would presume that they're happy
to negotiate down from that that's the
starting position
yes but the so far that hasn't happened
I mean they've they've the Scottish
Scotland they've rejected seven and a
half percent I think that was on the off
on the table here as well I think
probably they'll have to settle
somewhere around 10
um but it's clear that the government
want to
um to an extent control the agenda on
this they don't want to seem like they
are being bossed around by the unions
because that would that you know that
would that would be an admission of
failure for them and for for their
constituency so it's it really is a
Mexican standoff here because the
government can't really if they start to
give in to what they would term you know
blackmail then they will not they will
not have you know they will lose
whatever core support for them still
remain so it's very difficult
um I think that at the end of the day
yes but you're right people do support
nurses and evidence drivers probably
more than I suspect than they support
rail workers who tend to get paid a lot
more anyway so I think and I think that
any conversation around the NHS is
hugely emotive and understandably so
because it's something that we all feel
quite connected to Rachel shabby and
Sarah Vine and that is what we are going
to talk about the Daily Express they're
saying that he's had a hero's welcome
and that promise of Patriot missiles for
zelenski Sarah
well he's he's he's very
um I mean he's a brilliant man actually
I mean he's very he's very intent on
making sure that support
for his country doesn't sort of
fall off the front pages I mean and and
that's that's you know you know I don't
think I've ever seen anyone with quite
such as talent for for making sure that
his cause is is top of the news agenda
and that's what's going to save him
because of course you know so many of
these conflicts happen I mean not not
necessarily as as big as this one but
there are many conflicts going on around
the world and they do fall off the front
page but with zielinski is a figurehead
that's just not ever going to happen and
I think he is his efforts are heroic I
mean he's a he's a he's a very
inspirational figure and and it's
interesting because his story is just so
bizarre in so many ways because you know
he was a sort of Entertainer and now
he's become this great General
um extraordinary yes and he's pictured
on the front page walking with President
Biden at the front page of the financial
times at the White House this is the
300th day of the war in Ukraine and at a
moment when we know that President Putin
has stepped up the assault against
Ukraine attacking the the infrastructure
in his speech to the the White House he
ended by saying glory to Ukraine and
that has to be the the wish of the
international World Sarah certainly of
Joe Biden and he made that clear this
evening sorry Rachel definitely and I
was trying to bring Rachel in there
sorry Rachel
sure absolutely and um you know what
it's it's interesting when you when we
hear that you know this is his first
trip outside of Ukraine since the start
of the war 10 months ago 300 days
an awfully long time
um and just you know to think about that
length of time that ukrainians have been
dealing with this horrendous uh military
Invasion From Russia but of course
you're right that um you know zielinski
will be wanting to maintain a sense of
support and get those assurances from
the U.S which and and the Western World
and NATO which so far have been
forthcoming
um I think it's been something like 65
billion dollars of uh U.S military and
non-military Aid since the start of the
war
um and also this sort of assumption that
uh zielinski would be able to and
Ukraine would be able to determine the
terms of the eventual negotiation that
will that will end the war sooner rather
than later but of course that's always
the calibration and you know I think the
Russian propaganda Rachel was very much
sorry to cut you but we've run out of
time